since we're opening this can of worms
let's talk about this for just for just
one quick second i knew i know a guy and
uh his he's separated from his wife and
his kids are in israel
and his daughter's bot mitzvah is coming
up
and it looks like that the judge is
going to actually order the kids to stay
in israel
and so he
and in israel you can't enter the
country unless you have a vaccine
so what does that guy do the choice is
and he's
just mega opposed to the vaccine his
grandparents were you know captured by
the nazis like he has a history with
this
forced medical procedures et cetera
he was faced with
get the vaccine and see his kids
or don't get the vaccine and maybe never
see his kids again
that is a extremely difficult situation
to be put in if you believe very if
you're very adamantly opposed to the
vaccines and the mandates
and i don't think any of us would argue
here that this guy should never see his
kids again
right so what that clearly lays out for
us is that there is it is a personal
decision about this
and it's a spectrum
and so i don't fault the guy for getting
the vaccine to go see his kids it broke
his heart
like it tore him up because he didn't
want to do it because he was opposed to
it and he hated it but they put him in a
situation where it was like see the kids
or get don't don't get the vaccine but
that's that's how they win and that's
this is the big this is the big
challenge the logic of it is simple
go for someone's children and you will
have a slave
they win yeah as long as people there's
no escaping here
there's that guy there's multiple
options there's multiple ways of trying
to go through the system uh with the
system not looking there's i'm not
advocating for any illegal activities
but if there's a will there's a way
compliance isn't the easiest way it's
going to be the the easiest way for the
moment but in the long term it's going
to be the most difficult way for
everyone else including that person who
you know compromised his morals to
comply with the state so there's many
different ways around the differences
compromise one element of his morals to
honor the rest of his morals
i don't
again i don't agree with that kind of
argument there's many different avenues
that people could walk down that doesn't
include compliance that could still
allow him to see his children in many
different ways in many different avenues
and i think you should ex you should
explore all of those options until
there's not an option possible flying to
what like fake vaccine cards and things
like this again i'm not here to advocate
any of that uh i think advocating that
is even a felony under the fbi i mean
there's human rights legal proceedings
he could get a lawyer he could file
lawsuits he could say i will not you
know the government can't mandate a
medical procedure and take my kids from
me meet in another country uh have a
mediator come in and say hey okay let's
go meet in egypt or let's go meet in
turkey let's go meet somewhere nearby
and establish that we're going to be
doing this in some sort of way that
doesn't that infringe on my value that
assumes that he has a cooperative
ex-wife yeah okay but but you know
there's there's
a little there's a lot but hold on you
bring up an ex-wife now we're talking
about two civil parties and a government
entity so it's much different from an
individual versus the government when
there's a civil case between two
individuals sure my point is is that if
there's a spectrum and it's hard and
there's a decision to be made at some
point and the fact that the decision
exists is a symptom of the problem uh
not a contributor to the problem it's
actually there there is something more
simple if everyone said no there
wouldn't be a problem the problem is
that people bend the knee
and that's
right if you're the one if you're the
one
left resisting you you've got no one
with you
and that's why i've always been the kind
of person that says i would rather live
in a van down by the river than
compromise and and you know the only way
this is ever going to end if is if
people stop complying you cannot comply
your way out of tyranny i said this a
couple weeks ago it's impossible it's
impossible because they're going to keep
pushing you you're going to see the
enemy more and more the nba's mandated
boosters oh yeah the nba has told all
players coaches and referees that you
have to have a booster shot if you got
the johnson and johnson after two months
and then and the pfizer modern after six
months
obviously this was coming we knew this
was going to happen and now the cdc's
already said weeks ago they may change
the definition of fully vaccinated of
course they're going to
so it's only going to get worse and you
look at the inflation you look at the
food shortages you look at the price of
a turkey this year it's insane doubled
it's doubled double they're calling it
meat flation that's happening right now
not just bacon's up 20 yeah so the
people who said i got i got to
prioritize feeding my kid
congratulations by complying you have
taken the food out of their mouths
short-term gains for long-term
sacrifices sacrificing the future of
your children because it's easier now
you look
you take a look at the at the long hard
road and way off in the distance you see
paradise and you take a look at the
short trip over the bridge and the
bridge collapse and you end up getting
washed away sometimes you people got to
realize that life is not easy life is
not fair it takes hard work and you have
to you have to face the challenges head
on because when you take the easy route
you make everything worse
not always but often predominantly
especially it's never easy it's never an
easy it's whenever you do something
cheap uh i think that's the way of
describing this it's gonna come back and
haunt you and when more and more people
comply i mean people complied in israel
they just said we'll do anything we'll
go along with the vaccine passports
we'll get vaccinated everything will be
fine the government said well well well
no now you need a booster shot now we
need a third shot now they're even
talking about a fourth shot so with him
complying and saying yes i'll i'll go
buy your rules i'll go buy the four
fourth shot's already official for
immunocompromised so they're the but not
mandated a part of the official passport
system which they will be implementing
very soon and then the fifth shot and
then then we're talking about what
hepatitis shots or university of denver
has already mandated flu shots yeah
compliance is my favorite was the yahoo
news story said nba recommends boosters
for all you know referees and everything
and then later on it said if you don't
do it you'll be subject to all the same
restrictions blah blah blah so it's a
mandate there was a really cool guy from
the nba uh at the national conservative
conservativism conference as a matter of
fact isaac judah uh orlando magic sixth
round or sixth pick overall this is like
big time player right uh and he came and
sat on stage with dave rubin whoa yeah
dude nba six foot 11. look look isaac
judah oh seeing people like kyrie irving
aaron rodgers people who are willing to
speak out and stand up for what they
believe in this is fantastic now aaron
rodgers apparently lied about his you
know immunization or whatever and i he
should have spoken up and just been true
and honest from the get-go but i think
when we start seeing celebrities and
athletes
speak out in defense of individual
liberties individual rights
that's a good thing that's an amazing
thing and we need to encourage more it
was amazing to see him at the conference
and i'll admit i thought that the crowd
was just a little too excited the fact
that there was like an african american
guy there wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait that's every conservative
conference these days
[Music]
i mean that's you know that's the vibe
right uh but that guy has not been in a
conference like that that guy was super
well spoken very intelligent and uh made
his case very articulate well the media
his uh natural immunity etc well the
media attacked him viciously because he
wasn't going along
and and he
did a whole press conference where he
addressed this entire matter and brought
up points very eloquently and was
talking about all the scientific issues
that actually mattered that that i would
everyone was like i wish this guy was dr
fauci because he explained scientific
terms in such an easy simple way that
that made a lot of people understand his
position and they stopped attacking him
because of the way that he he approached
this situation without getting angry
without attacking without yelling
without freaking out and just said okay
here let me just explain myself calmly
rationally and because of that they
stopped attacking him he's still playing
um
something something we've brought up a
lot
there are a lot of celebrities that
watch his show they message me
definitely there's a lot of
famous athletes actors musicians
and
unfortunately they always say the same
thing i won't speak up right exactly and
i'm like dude you're who needs to speak
up you got two million followers right
make a post look at look at demi lovato
she she became an ambassador for gaia
and now they're attacking her saying
she's like it's a conspiracy website and
it's like it's a yoga and like holistic
health like forum or something they're
just
anyone that tries to deviate from the
control of the corporate establishment
is smeared
anybody here's a question for you i
don't know the answer did george
washington pay the stamp tax
i don't know no idea if the answer is
yes then all this stuff can we can just
throw this whole argument in the trash
because he complied because he complied
because he waited until the right moment
to make his move
anybody out there did george washington
pay the stamp tax did sam adams pay the
t tax did they pay the tax on the t
before the tea party let's get this
answer because that could put this
question to bed yeah yeah but jack
you're not making any moves
what do you mean well the argument is
like you just got to comply comply and
then and then go against 1965 or 1765
right give me nine years let's see
nine
years or 11 actually the big difference
is though is that
communicating took months
so if you took 11 years well if you were
a rep in virginia communicating with new
york about revolutionary ideas sure it's
a couple weeks to send a letter sure but
but so the actual conversation could be
months unless you came down for a
special meeting in philadelphia or
something i would love to know if any of
our founding fathers thomas jefferson
hamilton if any of those guys paid the
stamp tax at any point in their life
because if they did let's talk about it
why don't we just google it i just tried
it didn't come up jack you're just
trying to justify compliance i haven't i
haven't worked i haven't taken the
vaccine my kids haven't taken the
vaccine i don't know why everybody's
giving me a effing hard time about
having a conversation for people in
america that are struggling with this
issue well i am not vaccinated everybody
well well jack i appreciate the
conversation i think it's an important
one i'm happy we were able to have to
have that's why i wasn't here last week
two weeks ago when i got the call that
cass castle was under you know attacked
by the coronavirus i was like i'm not
going because i don't have the vaccine
well to be fair we didn't know for sure
at the time i know but lydia was like
everybody's sick dude i'm sorry
and here's one of the problems with the
testing mandate is we had four tests be
negative right and so we were like tests
cleared us we're good it's probably a
cold and then turns out you know yeah
so you know this a cursory glance at the
stamp act just mentions that the the
colonists viewed as a violation of their
rights uh they protested it but as to
whether or not they were paying it
good question
so you're saying that with the boston
tea party they should have uh you know
complied and not done what i'm what i'm
saying you're saying what i'm saying is
that there's a matrix to make decisions
as to whether this action is going to
have the desired outcome
or if it's only going to be deleterious
to yourself or harmful to yourself
there's a lot to consider
and not everybody even the most
venerated people in our history the
people you call patriots the people that
founded this country i bet you they
didn't resist every single moment
of tyranny before they finally had had
enough
and and actually like the things that
they revolted over in some cases pale in
comparison to the things that we're
dealing with now but
the point is is i think that there is a
a matrix by which you can make these
decisions that's probably different for
each person and it's just an interesting
historical question i have an answer for
you what uh benjamin franklin actually
suggested the appointment of john hughes
as the agent for pennsylvania to
implement the the stamp to be a stamp
distributor not aware of the turmoil
that the tax would create between
american british relations to simplify
when that when when the act was
implemented
people had to actually engage with it
before they understood it was bad and
then rejected so it seems like what
happened was the government said we're
implementing this a bunch of political
leaders were like okay and then they
started talking about it and then over
time because communication was slower
back then people started protesting in
the streets for like five years there
were protests over this so once people
were impacted by it understood the
ramifications they started rejecting it
but did they have did they pay the stamp
tax in the meantime while they were uh
while they were protesting i think i
think the fair uh during the protests
probably not probably what happened was
and again this is speculation you know
totally we should get a historian on
here but what i can say is initially
they did pay it and what likely happened
is they gradually began not paying it as
the protests expanded right so as
opposition grew people said i won't
comply but that is to say that means
people who
want the vaccines and believe in the
mandates of course will comply yeah but
that also means that people who protest
and oppose it would not comply
yeah
interesting historical question i'd love
to dig deeper on that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member
all of these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time